[Music]  it's time for et's social study your  quick look at what the stars are posting  online we'll definitely be ready  JLo was obviously ready for Valentine's  Day she showed off this massive flower  display now the question is who are they  from  just perfect Jessica Simpson celebrated  v-day with her hubby Eric Johnson with  these pics she captioned to them at  fifty shades of pink quite the change  from the couple's racy Fifty Shades of  Grey themed shoot from 2015 with  everybody a racy pic from it this year  Harry Potter actress Scarlett Byrne  posing nude for Playboy she is engaged  to mags chief creative officer Hugh  Hefner son Cooper and his Colton Haynes  engaged the former arrow star sparked  rumours with this Valentine's Day pic  embracing celebrity florists Jeff Latham  surrounded by roses  Colton captioned the romantic shot the  most special day of my life live your  best life why not